[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro des matins du
sénat cinq mois jour pour jour après
lincendie de lusine lubrizol la ministre
de la transition écologique a été
auditionné au sénat la commission
denquête en charge de cette audition et
vous le savez chargé d'évaluer
l'intervention des services de l'état
dans la gestion de l'incendié
et devant cette commission est bien
elizabeth borgne a estimé qu'il fallait
sans doute renforcer les sanctions en
matière d'atteinte à l'environnement au
regard de l'audition on en reparle juste
après quoi la ministre nous allons
commencer notre notre audition plutôt
votre audition
c'est à priori la dernière audition de
notre commission denquête donc sommes
très heureux de vous entendre
aujourd'hui comme vous le savez il ya
tout juste cinq mois jour pour jour se
déclencher un incendie de lusine
lubrizol si cet incendie a été
rapidement maîtrisé l'ampleur du panache
la persistance d'odeurs sur la ville de
rouen pendant plusieurs semaines ont
alimenté un sentiment de colère et
d'incompréhension
le 2 octobre dès le 2 octobre vous avez
fait parvenir au préfet une instruction
le constituant une première réponse
après l incendie
ma première question sera de vous
demander quels retours vous avez eue par
rapport à ces recommandations est alors
mise en oeuvre nous avons été il y a pas
très longtemps il ya quelques semaines à
peine
dans le rhône dans la vallée de la
chimie nous avons été assez étonné de
découvrir que sur de nombreux sites
seveso il n'y avait jamais eu d'exercice
menées en dehors des heures ouvrées ce
qui nous paraît petit peu lacunaire et
donc nous souhaiterions savoir également
si sur ce sujet les choses sont en phase
d'évolution
il y a deux semaines vous avez dévoilé
un plan d'action pour éviter qu'un
nouvel accident de même ampleur
se reproduisent et vous avez notamment
annoncé une augmentation de 50% du
nombre des contrôles
c'est un objectif ambitieux auquel nous
ne pouvons que souscrire
simplement nous nous interrogeons sur la
tonalité d'un tel objectif
avec des effectifs qui a priori ne
devrait pas augmenter en proportion est
donc nous souhaitons vous puissiez nous
donner quelques éléments sur ce sur ce
point et puis le dernier sujet que je
voulais évoquer avant de vous laisser à
paroles et puis bien sûr que mes
collègues puissent vous vous interrogez
c'est que s'il est certainement
important de renforcer les contrôles
il est à notre sens encore plus
important de vérifier et de s'assurer
que ces contrôles sont suivies d'effet
et à cet égard c'est pour nous un sujet
d'interrogation et même d'un
satisfaction de constater que notamment
dans l'usiné de briesen et s'était
relevé dans l'arrêté de mise en demeure
formulée par par le préfet il y avait un
certain nombre de remarques qui avait
été formulée par le real
un an et demi plus tôt et plus
précisément le 19 avril 2018
concernant notamment le plan de défense
incendie pour une meilleure prise en
compte des restes et les récipients
mobile et donc je là aussi nous
aimerions vous entendre sur ce sujet
à notre avis c'est quand même pas normal
comme pas légitime que des remarques
aussi importante de la part des services
de l'état puisse rester lettre morte
voilà quelques points sur lesquels je
voulais que je voulais évoquer avant de
de vous laisser la parole je me dois de
vous rappeler que vous êtes devant une
commission d enquête parlementaire que
tout témoignage mensonger est puni de
cinq ans d'emprisonnement et de 75000
euros d'amande et donc je vais vous
demander
malama ministre de bien vouloir prêter
serment de dire la vérité toute la
vérité rien que la vérité de lever la
main droite et de dire je le jure merci
donc nous je vous laisse la parole avant
de donner la parole aux rapporteurs est
bon la commission si monsieur le
président mesdames les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
voudrais tout d'abord vous remercier de
me donner à nouveau l'occasion
d'exprimer de vente vous sur cette
catastrophe industrielle qui comme vous
l'avez rappelé à frapper les habitants
de rouen de la seine maritime et au delà
le 26 septembre dernier
je voudrais redire que dès les premières
heures de cet incendie hors norme
l'ensemble des services de l'état ont
été pleinement mobilisées en premier
lieu je voudrais rappeler que
l'intervention des sapeurs pompiers a
été exemplaire les 280 pompiers qui ont
été mobilisés
on ferait pour fait preuve d'un immense
courage et je voudrais à nouveau les
remercier grâce à eux
malgré la violence de l'incendié on ne
déplore aucun blessé et a fortiori aucun
mort je voudrais aussi souligner
l'implication des agents de la dréal
normandie depuis la fuite de mercaptan
sur le site de lubrizol en 2013 ce sont
pas moins de 39 inspection qui ont été
réalisés en six ans ces inspections ont
permis de tester le plan d'opération
interne de lubrizol ou de renforcer les
dispositifs de prévention des incendies
et puis je rappelle que la mise en
oeuvre du plan de prévention des risques
technologiques
lubrizol avait également permis de
réduire deux facteurs de risque
importants avec la suppression d'une
cuve de gpl et d'une cuve d'acide
chlorhydrique qui était initialement à
proximité des bâtiments qui ont brûlé sa
clairement permis d'éviter des
conséquences encore plus dramatiques
le gouvernement s'est engagé à faire
face aux conséquences environnementales
et sanitaires de cet accident dans la
transparence la plus absolue
c'est pourquoi toutes les informations
toutes les données scientifiques et
leurs interprétations ont été rendus
publics
elles ont été présentées lors des
comités de dialogue et de transparence
qui se sont mis en place et donc comité
qui s'est réuni à six reprises
elles ont aussi été systématiquement
mises en ligne sur le site de la
préfecture de seine-maritime et donc
sont accessibles à tous par ailleurs
nous avons imposé la mise en place d'une
surveillance environnementale post
accidentelle avec deux arrêtés de
mesures d'urgence en date du 26
septembre pour lubrizol du 30 septembre
au normandy logistique dans les jours
qui ont suivi l'incendié pour
l'alimentation ce sont plus de 5000
prélève 500 pardon prélèvements qui ont
été réalisés dont les résultats se sont
révélés inférieurs aux normes
applicables les prélèvements vont se
poursuivre dans la durée pour vérifier
que tous les résultats restent bien
conforme
en ce qui concerne les retombées les
résultats sont cohérents avec le bruit
de fond c'est à dire la qualité moyenne
des sols avant l' incendie notamment
pour les hydrocarbures les métaux et les
dioxines quelques traces ont été mesurés
de soufre de zinc et de phosphore
éléments qui étaient bien présents dans
les produits de lubrizol leur très
faible concentration ne nécessite pas de
mesures de précaution particulières dans
les sols plus de mille prélèvements ont
été réalisés dans les 5 125 communes
potentiellement touchés par le panache
en raison d'une saturation des
laboratoires d'analysés
seule une première série de résultats
pour 23 communes autour de rouen a été
rendu disponible
ces premiers résultats ne présentent pas
d'anomalie particulières mises à part
quelques traces de plomb de mercure et
de benzo a pyrène sans qu'il soit
possible de les relier à l' incendie
par ailleurs j'ai demandé dès le 4
octobre la réalisation d'un protocole de
suivi des eaux de surface et de la
biodiversité à l' agence française de la
biodiversité désormais ou fb aux agences
de l'eau de seine normandie date wav
artois picardie à l'office national des
forêts est au centre de documentation de
recherche et d'expérimentations sur les
pollutions accidentelles des eaux
le cèdre les analyses réalisées sur les
cours d'eau présentent de faibles
concentrations en hydrocarbures dont le
lien avec l'accident n'est pas établi
compte tenu de leur localisation
géographique aucune mortalité piscicole
n'a été relevé en dehors de la darse qui
a accueilli une partie des eaux
d'extinction de l'incendié
le diagnostic complet de cet état des
milieux est attendu pour le mois d'avril
et il permettra de mener une étude
quantitative des risques sanitaires dont
les résultats seront ensuite expertisées
par les agences sanitaires
je pense qu'on peut dire que c'est la
première fois que des analyses sont
réalisées sur un spectre aussi large de
polluants et sur des volumes aussi
important elles permettent d'apporter
une information rigoureuse sur les
conséquences sanitaires et
environnementales de ce sinistre
conformément à notre engagement de
transparence pour éviter qu'un tel
accident ne se reproduise
nous avons tiré des premières leçons de
cet accident dès la survenue d'accidents
j'avais dirigeante et une mission
d'inspection générale en l'occurrence le
cgedd et le cge des recommandations de
cette mission était présenté lors du
conseil supérieur de la prévention des
risques technologiques le 13 janvier et
les membres de ce conseil mais eux-mêmes
fait part de leurs réflexions et
propositions
je précise que les problématiques
relatives à la gestion de crise font
l'objet d'une mission d'inspection
générale qui rendra ses conclusions au
printemps
le plan d'action que j'ai présenté le 11
février sera ainsi complété dans les
prochains mois sur les questions de l'
alerte des populations et du
développement de la culture du risque
le premier premier axe du plan d'action
que j'ai présentées consiste à renforcer
la transparence
lorsqu'un accident industriel a lieu en
mettant à disposition l'ensemble des
informations pertinentes lors de l'
incendie le 26 septembre nous avons eu
des difficultés à récupérer une liste
précise et utilisables des produits
impliqué dans l' incendie pour garantir
une parfaite transparence
nous allons imposer que soient mis à
disposition du public dès la survenue de
l'accident et dans des termes
intelligible par les non spécialistes
la nature et la quantité des produits
stockés d'autre part les délais
d'analystes sont encore trop long ce que
j'ai évoquées notamment sur le fait que
seuls les résultats de 23 communes sont
aujourd'hui connus et c'est pourquoi
nous demanderons aux industriels
d'identifier en amont les moyens de
prélèvements et des analyses associées
enfin des études viendront compléter les
valeurs toxicologiques de référence et
les valeurs de bruit de fond sur un
éventail de polluants plus large pour
faciliter l'interprétation des valeurs
mesurées fait notamment des mesures de
dioxine dans l'environnement aujourd'hui
on a pas on n'a pas deux valeurs nini
toxicologiques de référence
on sait qu'on en a dans les laits
produits alimentaires mais dans
l'environnement il n'y en a pas et par
ailleurs on n'a évidemment pas la
cartographie de l'ensemble des teneurs
en bruit de fond sur ces différents
polluants
donc ça veut dire que c'est un axe de
travail très très lourd de pouvoir
disposer de l'ensemble de ses valeurs
deuxième axe nous devons évidemment
éviter que des incendies de 7 dans cette
ampleur se déclenche à nouveau donc
une enquête judiciaire est toujours en
cours donc nous n'avons pas d'éléments
sur l'origine de l'incendié mais on sait
que son développement rapide découle
notamment de la présence d'une nappe
enflammé qui a propagé l'incendié entre
plusieurs stockage ce qui nous amène à
envisager plusieurs axes d'amélioration
pour limiter précisément la probable
propagation de l'incendié au sein des
différents stockage d'un même site
donc nous allons revoir les mesures de
compartimentage la disposition des
stockage des produits et la conception
des cuvettes de rétention
et puis il nous faut aussi éviter la
propagation d'un incendie entre des
sites voisins
nous allons désormais inspecté
systématiquement l'ensemble des
installations classées dans un rayon de
100 mètres autour des sites seveso
enfin les moyens de d'extinction sur le
site lubrizol se sont révélés
insuffisants ce qui a nécessité de
mettre en place en urgence des bateaux
pompes sur la scène des émules soeur
aussi les produits que les pompiers
mélangent à l'eau pour obtenir de la
mousse ont dû être recherchés parmi les
industriels voisins pendant l' incendie
donc nous allons désormais demander aux
industriels d'identifier en amont des
capacités suffisantes d'eau d'extinction
et des mules soeur l'ensemble des
nouvelles obligations seront testés lors
d'exercices réguliers obligatoirement
une fois par an pour les sites seveso
seuil haut
alors que la pratique est d'une fois
tous les trois ans actuellement
nous allons donc renforcer nos moyens de
contrôle et d'en quête pour s'assurer
que ces nouvelles réglementations soient
bien appliquées
donc j'ai en effet indiqué que nous nous
fixons l'objectif d'augmenter de 50% le
nombre de contrôles d'ici la fin du
quinquennat
l'atteinte de cet objectif reposera sur
une réduction des charges
administratives des inspecteurs des
installations classées notamment par le
développement d'outils numériques
et puis aussi en privilégiant des
contrôles sur site alors que ces
dernières années et finalement les
inspecteurs ont été de plus en plus
chargé par de l'instruction de dossiers
avec une
arch particulières liées précisément à
la mise en place des pprt qui sont
quasiment tous élaborés aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui a représenté une charge
administrative très importante pour nous
explique nos inspecteurs en tout cas ce
travail il va être mené et on ajustera
le cas échéant les effectifs
une fois qu'on aura fait ses différentes
optimisations pour atteindre l'objectif
que j'ai fixé de 50% de contrôles
supplémentaires
et puis dernier point j'ai aussi
souhaité que l'on puisse disposer dans
le domaine des risques industriels des
risques technologiques d'un bureau d'
enquête accident donc je pense que c'est
des outils qui existent par exemple dans
tous les domaines des transports aériens
terrestres maritimes et c'est très
précieux de pouvoir mobiliser cette
expertise non pas pour double nail
enquête judiciaire
mais pour tirer le plus rapidement
possible toutes les conséquences d'un
accident majeur
donc je le redis un gouvernement s'est
engagé à présenter les faits tels qu'ils
sont en toute transparence et attirer le
retour d'expérience de cet accident
le plan d'action que j'ai présenté le 11
février répondait à cet objectif de
prendre au plus vite les dispositions
pour éviter que de tels qu'un tel
accident se reproduise alors peut-être
pour revenir sur les questions que vous
avez évoqué monsieur le président donc
je vous confirme qu'effectivement
j'avais saisi lé préfet pour demander
que les dréal prennent la tâche des
responsables de l'ensemble des sites
seveso
la demande étant de vérifier le
dimensionnement et le caractère
opérationnel des mesures de maîtrise des
risques en particulier ce qui permet de
prévenir des incendies que des exercices
de préparation qui sont indispensables
pour vérifier l'effectivité des mesures
de protection soient réalisés en période
nocturne de vérifier que les exploitants
dispose en temps réel d'une connaissance
de la nature et des quantités de
produits donc la réglementation va être
ajusté sur ce point là
98 % des exploitants ou fait un retour
au préfet notamment sur leur capacité à
produire les éléments tel que demandé
et naturellement nous allons aussi nous
assurer qu'on pourra dans les prochains
mois faire des exercices en période
nocturne ce qui devrait théoriquement
être le cas peut-être vous dire aussi
que sur les préconisations les
recommandations ou les injonctions qui
avait été donnée par la dalle led real
ces mesures notamment celle qui avait
été prescrite pour améliorer la défense
incendie avait fait l'objet d'une mise
en heure qui ensuite a pu être relevée
en 2010 mise en oeuvre en 2010 est levée
en 2018
l'exploitant sept ans mis en conformité
et puis également donc je pense que
toutes ces recommandations ont aussi
contribué à améliorer le plan de le plan
le pee wee le plan opérationnel interne
de l'entreprise ce qui a certainement
aussi faciliter la gestion de cet
incendie
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
enfin lorsque des prescriptions sont
fait ce qu'on prend de monsieur le
directeur général le case échéance a
abouti à des mises en demeures qui font
l'objet de sanctions importantes
voilà donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui s'il
n'y a pas de régularisation il peut y
avoir des astreintes administrative
voire des suspensions d'autorisation
d'exploiter peut-être cela renvoie aussi
à projet de loi que vous avez dû
examiner porté par nicole belloubet sur
d'autres outils qui peuvent permettre
d'obtenir la réparation de préjudices et
des sanctions dissuasives sans passer
par une suspension d'exploitation qui
pour le coup peut paraître effectivement
difficile à prononcer par les par les
représentants de l'état bien je
reviendrai peut-être sur ce que vous
venez de dire mais j'ai tout de suite
donné la parole à une bonne foi notre co
rapporteurs que je sais qu'elle a une
contrainte horaire je ne reviendrai sur
ce que vous avez dit et donc je donne la
parole tout de suite la même bonne foi
oui merci monsieur le président je vais
devoir m'absenter dans les minutes qui
suivent et géo prix des médias vouloir
m'excuser je voulais
madame la ministre vous interpellez nous
sommes depuis plusieurs mois maintenant
en train de travailler sur donc les dans
le cadre cette commission d' enquête sur
les suites des 110 du briol vous avez
fait vous même certain nombre de
recommandations
comme on lui rappelait le président tout
à l'heure par exemple augmenter les
contrôles dans des installations
classées pour la préservation de
l'environnement icpe
parallèlement le gouvernement est en
train de présenter et c'est en ce moment
je crois d'ailleurs une commission
spéciale un projet de loi accélération
et simplification de l'action publique
et dans ce projet de loi aux articles 24
25 et 26 si je regarde l'article 24 pour
les installations classées
l'installation d'une icpe il est dit que
l'article rang facultatif
la consultation par le préfet du coders
qui est le conseil départemental de
l'environnement et des risques
sanitaires et technologiques de la même
façon pour la commission départementale
de la nature des sites et des paysages
dans l'article 25
ce projet de loi dit recourir à une
simple consultation publique au lieu
d'une véritable enquête publique pour
les projets soumis à autorisation
environnementale pour l'article 26 il
dit autoriser le début des travaux avant
que l'autorité environnementale n'est
donné son autorisation ou encore alléger
les contrôles environnementaux
je considère pour ma part que ces
articles dans ce projet de loi sont
contradictoires contradictoire avec vos
recommandations préconisations et
contradictoires également avec la
décision du conseil continue
constitutionnel qui le 31 janvier 2020 a
clairement tranché en faveur de
l'intérêt général au travers de la
préservation de l'environnement
face à la liberté d'entreprendre donc si
je comprends bien la logique qui anime
ce projet de loi qui est plus une
une logique de bercy et donc d'économies
je considère pour ma part qu'elle va à
l'encontre des problématiques
environnementales et donc je voulais
bien évidemment interrogé la ministre de
l'environnement sur sur cette situation
que je trouve quand même dommageable et
regrettable au regard des du
renforcement que nous devons avoir plus
tôt en matière de droit environnemental
résumé se portent un d'alléger les
contraintes en matière environnementale
après ce qui s'est passé
l'analyste alors moi je ne partage pas
la lecture que le projet de loi que vous
avez mentionné restreindrait notre
capacité à contrôler les risques
technologiques dans les installations
classées je sais que certains nombres
dungey environnementales ont soulevé des
questions et on aura l'occasion de
d'échangés également avec elle
s'agissant par exemple de la
consultation du coderst vous savez qu'on
est dans une situation assez paradoxale
dans laquelle la saisine du coderst est
facultative dans le cadre
d'autorisations et sur les installations
moindre importance qui sont soumis à
enregistrement
aujourd'hui la saisine est obligatoire
donc on voit qu'à force de modifier les
textes on arrive à une situation qui est
pas tout à fait logique
moi je pense qu'on peut tout de même
enfin je pense qu'on peut s'appuyer sur
des préfets pour prendre des décisions
de bon sens et j'imagine mal pas je peux
mieux espérer parce que sinon le monde
deviendrait compliqué et je pense que je
ne vois pas un préfet qui se
dispenserait de saisir le coderst sur
une autorisation enfin sur une décision
et je rappelle que c'est possible pour
des catégories d'établissements
présentant plus de risques puisque c'est
possible en cas d'autorisation et
aujourd'hui ça ne l'est pas en cas
d'enregistrement mais je ne vois pas un
préfet qu'ils ne soumettraient pas au
coderst qui ne recueillerait pas l'avis
du coderst sur une décision concernant
un projet sensible donc c'est simplement
de permettre sur des dossiers qui n'ont
pas une sensibilité particulière de
pouvoir faire ce pour les dossiers
soumis enregistrements ce qui est
possible aujourd'hui sur des dossiers
plus importants soumis à autorisation
je pense qu'en aucun cas ça ne peut
s'analyser comme une moindre précaution
sur d autorisation icpe
de la même façon sur la possibilité de
d'avoir une consultation du public
électronique et non pas une enquête
publique je rappelle que cette faculté
n'existe pas pour les projets qui sont
soumis à évaluation environnementale
donc les projets importants les projets
les plus impactants pour l'environnement
qui sont donc soumis à évaluation
environnementale feront nécessairement
l'objet d'une enquête publique
voilà ensuite la consultation
électronique je pense que tout ça peut
aussi discuter pour savoir si c'est plus
accessible
quand on a une consultation du public
que d'avoir un dossier d'un commissaire
enquêteur 20 dossiers sont soumis à une
enquête publique
qui n'est taxée si par définition qu'à
ceux qui se rendront dans le lieu où le
dossier est présenté je pense qu'on peut
poursuivre les échanges sur la garantie
que donnent les commissaires enquêteurs
et la façon dont on peut s'assurer quand
on est en consultation électronique
d'avoir ces mêmes garanties de
transparence sur la prise en compte des
différents avis qui ont été formulées
dans le cadre d'une consultation
électronique
voilà tout ça pour dire et pardon lépi
pour finir sur les la possibilité
d'engager des travaux sur une partie
d'un permis de construire
sans attendre la décision sur
l'autorisation environnementale
je vous aurez noté que c'est strictement
encadrée c'est à dire le cas dans lequel
on se place serait une construction dans
une zone dans lequel il n'y aurait pas d
enjeu d'artificialisation de
défrichement et donc pas d'enjeu par
exemple en termes de loi sur l'eau ou
d'espèces protégées dans laquelle on
pourrait démarrer les travaux on va dire
le gros oeuvre en prenant le risque de
ne pas avoir ensuite la faculté
d'exploiter l'installation donc je pense
qu'on est sur un certain nombre de cas
limités et de toute façon en aucun cas
cela ne conduit à baisser la garde sur
les exigences préalables à une
autorisation d'installation classée pour
la protection de l'environnement
merci beaucoup de deux points quand même
par rapport à ce qu d'état leur bon
d'abord les pprt ils n'ont pas tous été
pris et ne reste comme quelques-uns qui
sont eux qui sont à prendre
et surtout vous avez eu l'air de
d'indiquer que toutes les prescriptions
étaient globalement mise en oeuvre des
orques dès lors qu'elle avait été
formulée moi j'ai je me suis fait
rapporté répondu à porter la lettre du
préfet de région du 17 décembre 2019
dont j'avais déjà lu certains extraits
aux hauts responsables de lubrizol ici
même en décembre qui montrent très
clairement qu'un certain nombre de
remarques formulées par le préfet de
région en 2018 n'était toujours pas pris
en compte au moment de au moment des
événements donc ça montre bien qu'il y a
à mon sens nécessité de vérifier
davantage la manière dont les mises en
demeures où les remarques sont prises en
compte par par les entreprises je crois
qu'il ya un vrai travail de ce côté là
et vous aviez l'air de minimiser un
petit peu cet aspect des choses dans
votre réponse
alors peut-être pour revenir sur les
pprt
tous ne sont pas arrêtées à ce jour mais
on à 385 pprt sur les 390 prescrit qui
sont qui ont été élaborés donc il ya
cinq pprt plus complexes qui sont
toujours en cours d'élaboration
une fois qu'on a cédé prt ça ne veut pas
dire qu'ils sont tous mis en oeuvre et
on sait qu'on a de type de prescription
dans les pprt à la fois des biens qui
peuvent faire l'objet d'une
expropriation ou d'un droit de
délaissement sur lesquels c'est
compliqué de savoir s'agissant du droit
de délaissement hacker laquelle et le
stade d'avancement puisque ça suppose
que y est
initiative de la part du propriétaire
mais globalement on a un taux
d'avancement de 18% donc ça veut dire
que ces pprt certain temps à être
élaboré ne sont pas encore totalement
mis en oeuvre
et puis par ailleurs il ya tout ce qui
concerne les prescriptions de travaux et
là on a à peu près 16 mille logements
qui sont concernés par des prescriptions
de travaux sur lequel il est important
d'accompagner les propriétaires des
logements en question pour qu'ils
passent effectivement à l'acte de
réaliser des travaux aujourd'hui à 9000
logements qui ont fait l'objet d'un
accompagnement et on a eu l'occasion
par ailleurs deux d'améliorer les
modalités de prise en charge du reste à
charge avec une simplification des prêts
qu'ils pourront être mobilisés par les
propriétaires des logements
s'agissant de l'effectivité des enfin
sur la mise en oeuvre des prescriptions
qui ont été faites je relève simplement
qu'aujourd'hui quand on est pris en
infraction la réglementation icpe on
peut avoir une amende administrative que
s'il n'y a pas de régularisation il ya
la possibilité d'avoir une astreinte
administrative donc ce sont des sommes à
verser tous les jours jusqu'à la
régularisation et puis en plus fin à la
fin ça peut effectivement arriver une
suspension de l'autorisation voire à la
réalisation de travaux d'office c'est
sans doute perfectible et en particulier
c'est ce qui a pu être relevé qu'un
certain nombre de prescriptions n'avait
pas été mise en oeuvre en termes de
chiffre je peux
vous tenez le ski c'est ce qui a été
réalisé
je pense que c'est en 2018 19,86 amende
administrative en 2019 ce qui est le
chiffre le plus élevé depuis que cet
outil existe 139 astreintes
administratif de la même façon c'est le
chiffre le plus élevé 12 travaux deux
fils ont été effectuées ce qui est
conforme à la moyenne des dernières
années et 43 suspension d'activité ont
été prononcées merci je vais donner la
parole à la rapporteure même boîtier de
salon
désolé madame unissent mais c'est pas
dans les habitudes du sénat on n'a pas
répondu aux attentes de notre cabinet
qui souhaitaient avoir les questions
avant l'audition procède pas comme ça au
sénat mais je suis sûr que vous
arriverez très bien répondre néanmoins
maintenant à porter oui madame merci de
votre de votre rapport moi je vous avais
parlé donc d'une augmentation de
d'inspection de 50% d'ici 2022
mais est-ce qu'on peut envisager
réellement un nombre supplémentaire de
réflexion sans avoir les inspecteurs
sans en avoir un nombre supplémentaire
nous les avons auditionné ici et
effectivement ils se plaignent de la
charge de travail administratif qu'ils
ont à faire
médias - il semblerait qu'ils se
plaignent aussi du nombre réduit
2 j'adorais être aidé par de nouveaux
inspecteurs
est ce que dans des situations comme ça
il ne faudrait pas envisager d'avoir une
police des sites dédiés aux sites
industriels ou les inspecteurs
pourraient venir vérifier si ces sites
si ces sites respectent la
réglementation tout à l'heure nous avons
reçu l'assureur de lubrizol cette police
pourrait aussi demander les documents
fournis pour les assureurs puisque là on
se rend compte que finalement l'assureur
avait demandé certaines
certaines règles qui donc qui semble ne
pas avoir été respectée et puis pour
finir je j'ai commencé le ma première
question des auditions et je vais
terminer par puisqu'on termine ce soir
les auditions par la même question parce
que finalement j'ai pas été
on n'a pas répondu comment aujourd'hui
au 21ème siècle
à l'heure où l'homme va dans la lune
comment n'existe-t-il pas un registre
informatiques cryptés bien évidemment en
temps réel qui nous qui nous renseigne
sur d'abord la nature du contenu des
fûts la promiscuité avec certes avec
d'autres fut est anticipée de dire
'voilà sis à brügg ensemble voilà le
cocktail que ça va donner voilà les
effets qu'il va y avoir parce qu'il
semblerait que la liste du cocktail et
des produits émis vraiment longtemps à
être révélé donc aujourd'hui comment se
fait-il qu'à notre époque on ne puisse
pas mettre en place un registre
informatique qui nous renseigne sur ça
mais vraiment en temps réel merci le
rapporteur la ministre merci sur le
dernier point c'est bien ce que j'ai
décidé de va modifier la réglementation
pour s'assurer qu'à tout moment
l'industriel est capable de nous fournir
la liste et les quantités des produits
en cause dans l' incendie
ils sont aujourd'hui tenues de enfin de
tenir à jour la liste des produits sur
le site
en l'occurrence ce qu'on leur demandait
c'était quels sont les volumes et la
nature des produits mis en cause dans
l'incendié
quel est le cocktail ce qu'il va donner
et c'est là services intégrés en ce que
j'ai demandé ce qui serait bien c'est
que les pompiers puissent avoir ça
évidemment les services de la dréal
aussi et lorsque avant de partir sur un
incendie sur un site industriel que les
pompiers sache quelle l'équipement ils
doivent remettre pour affronter les
incendies donc c'est précisément ce que
j'ai décidé de demander aux industriels
d'être capable de fournir en cas d'
incendies immédiatement et non pas d'un
semaines plus tard la liste des
quantités de produits et on re précise
que dans l'étude de dangers ils devront
devront analyser en tout cas nous
fournir les informations sur les
produits susceptibles d'être produits
par la combustion des produits
stockables donc c'est bien ça qu'on a
demandé en termes de dispositions
techniques on tire les leçons au site
cet incendie ou s'agissant de normandie
logistique la fourniture des listes a
manifestement été compliquée par le fait
que l'ordinateur avait brûlé ou je ne
sais quoi donc on leur demandera de se
débrouiller pour avoir ces informations
sur un serveur qui ne risque pas d'être
rendue indisponible par l'incendié donc
je pense que sur ce plan là on est
parfaitement en ligne avec ce que vous
évoquez dans les mesures que j'ai que
j'ai annoncée je suis pas sûr de
comprendre votre question sur la police
dédiée à l'inspection des sites
industriels puisque pour moi c'est
précisément ce que sont les inspecteurs
des installations classées
c'est bien une police dédiée au seul
icpe qui est en charge à la fois de
l'instruction des dossiers et de
l'inspection des installations et ils
ont des pouvoirs de police
administrative
ils ont aussi la possibilité de dresser
d'aidé
procès verbaux qui seront transmis au
procureur donc là encore les
dispositions sur lesquelles on a
travaillé avec nicole belloubet aussi
sur la spécialisation des juridictions
devrait permettre peut-être d'avoir des
taux de poursuite un plus important
c'est ce qu'on en attend en tout cas
mais ses pouvoirs de police
administrative la capacité de
transmettre au procureur des procès des
procès verbaux
c'est tout à fait le ce que sont les
inspecteurs des installations classées
6e le terrain d'une manière plus
importante comme vous l'avez décidé en
ayant des inspections beaucoup plus
importante
donc l'objectif c'est d'augmenter des
inspections de terrain on va faire
l'analyse des marges de manoeuvre qu'on
peut leur donner avec des outils qui
allégeront les charges administratives
ensuite on aura une évaluation de ce
qu'il est vain de savoir si ça suffit à
faire le chemin nécessaire pour
atteindre les 50% de contrôle de plus
ces deux cas échéant renforcera les
effectifs des inspecteurs des
installations classées
permettez moi quand même de douter
malama ministre qu'on arrive d'ici la
fin du quinquennat augmenter le nombre
de contrôles de 50%
c'est un objectif très ambitieux c'est
bien être ambitieux mais s'il n'y a pas
les moyens en face des ambitions jeu
j'espère me tromper mais enfin ce sera
sera notée au procès verbal que quand ce
26 février 2020 j'ai quelques doutes
quant à l'atteinte des objectifs à moyen
constant thé monsieur le président
pourra faire le suivi régulièrement à
notre plan d'action quant à la quant à
la création de juridictions spécialisées
présenté par madame
belloubet pas plus tard qu'hier dans
notre assemblée
elle a clairement rappelé que ça ne
changerait rien sur des accidents type
du briol puisque ça resterait ça
resterait de la compétence de la
juridiction inter-régionale marseille et
paris qui sont aujourd'hui spécialisée
en juin sous le rappeler pour qu'il ait
pas d'ambiguïté pour un pour mes
collègues
monsieur son oui merci 1 ap la ministre
je me permets juste avant de vous saisir
de deux ou trois questions honnêtement
je vois pas l'intérêt d'une annonce
consistant à dire que vous voulez
augmenter de 50% les contrôles avant la
fin du quinquennat
je le dis posément je vois pas la vie
elle a commencé avant le canal continue
après je pense qu'il faut plutôt
regarder par rapport au nombre de sites
par rapport aux personnels dont vous
disposez par rapport à la manière dont
les choses peuvent s'organiser
permettez moi de dire je trouve ça un
effet d'annonce enfin un peu inutile
voilà je voulais aborder la question des
règles et de la réglementation pour
attirer notre attention est la vôtre sur
finalement les deux niveaux qui me
paraissent être pris en compte beaucoup
et demandé à la réglementation voire à
la loi je pense qu'il faut être attentif
enfin à pas vouloir légiférer sur tout
et en regard comme ça vous allez mieux
saisir ce que je veux dire
vous avez des opérateurs sur des sujets
comme seveso mais pas seulement mais en
tous les cas pour des dossiers comme
seveso qui sont des professionnels de
l'assurance qui ont des règles qui vont
donc au delà de la loi puisque
finalement c'est par une convention
entre les parties par un contrat qui est
signée que l'assureur garantit en plus
par des organismes de réassurance
propose est fixe des règles qui peuvent
être
plus contraignantes j'ai cru comprendre
à travers ce que j'ai lu dans la presse
que les alertes les contrôles ce qu'on
appelle des inspections faites sur le
terrain avait été suivie de
recommandations est normalement une
prescription est souvent comme ça n'est
pas mise en oeuvre va vous avez ce qu'on
la prime d'assurance qui augmente donc
ce que je veux dire par là c'est qu'il
s'agit pas de vouloir ni pour nous je
pense ni peut-être pour vous faire des
annonces qui expliquerait que demain on
aura réponse à tous je crois qu'il faut
être plus prudent et qu'il faut laisser
une part un cadre légal et ensuite
laissé aux parties la capacité de
trouver une solution et si ya pas de
solution parce qu'à un moment il peut y
avoir un risque de risques non
assurables ou de prix exorbitant dans ce
cas ça doit remonter un organisme qui
tire la sonnette d'alarmé
et puis qui saisit l'état je le dis
parce que je crois que c'est important
deuxièmement madame la ministre je suis
un peu surpris et j'ai écouté votre
propos liminaire vous citez toujours un
certain nombre d'organismes mais je me
dois de vous dire qui a au moins un
organisme associatif qui s'émeut d'être
toujours passer sous silence qui est un
organisme qui fait un travail je crois
enfin des organismes associatifs assez
remarquables qui sont les associations
agréées de surveillance de la qualité de
l'air qui agissent pour le compte de
l'état dans le cadre de missions de
service public avec une collégialité
d'acteurs et de partenaires qui les rend
parfaitement opérant avec une astreinte
h 24 avec des outils au service de tout
le monde est bien sûr sous l'autorité de
l'état
donc n'oubliez pas d'intégrer leur
présence n'oubliez pas désintégré parce
que ça s'est encore passé sur l'
incendie de la péniche ou dans le
premier ces eaux des îles n'était pas
mis dans la boucle honnêtement c'est
vraiment dommage l'état à des outils des
personnels qui sont compétents mobilisés
et mobilisables et vous donner le
sentiment tous les cas objectivement de
ne pas en tenir compte
donc je crois que c'est important enfin
ce que je voulais vous dire également
c'est en lien avec la première partie
c'est ça peut paraître un détail mais ce
n'est pas tout à fait un sur le rôle de
chacun parce que vous parle et parle du
dépôt sur rouen lubrizol
et quand vous vous allez avoir des
nouvelles règles peut-être avec de
nouvelles règles dans tous les cas plus
draconiennes il va falloir faire des
aménagements des règles de construction
bien il faut les ces nouvelles règles
ces nouveaux dispositifs il sera
important de les faire passer notamment
aux architectes ça parce que les règles
la loi et les règles d'assurance c'est
pas toujours les mêmes et dans ce cas là
c'est l'acteur économique c'est
l'entreprise qui se trouve pris entre
deux feux entre par exemple les
architectes l'iba si ça respecte la loi
et puis la chaleur qu'il émet non moi
j'ai besoin d'eux
je dirais de prescription plus
importante parce qu'il ya des risques
c'est ce que lisez notre collègue sur
les effets cocktails voilà madame la
ministre amah ministre oui faut écouter
c'est votre liberté de penser que c'est
en effet d'annonce de d'augmenter 50%
je pense que c'est parfaitement cohérent
avec ce que j'ai par ailleurs indiqué
sur la nécessité d'inspecter
systématiquement les les installations
classées dans un périmètre de 100 mètres
autour des sites seveso et je souhaite
par ailleurs en application de
l'instruction j'avais adressé au préfet
qui puissent effectivement y avoir des
exercices sur voilà le caractère
opérationnel dès plan d'opération
interne réalisés de jour comme de nuit
donc tout ça suppose qu'on renforce
effectivement les contrôles sur site et
la présence des inspecteurs et c'est ce
qui me conduit à évaluer ce besoin à une
augmentation de 50% étant entendu que je
peux pas non plus me satisfaire du fait
que l'on soit passé de 30 mille contrôle
en 2006 à 19000 contrôle
on va dire 19 725 contrôle en 2019 alors
même que le nombre d'inspecteurs à
augmenter significativement puisqu'on
était à 848 en 2001 et qu'on est à 1256
en 2011 a quasiment 1300 en 2019
vous voyez à un moment donné
manifestement on
la plus d'inspecteurs et on a moins de
contrôle donc c'est aussi ma
responsabilité de m'assurer qu'on
desserre condé charge les inspecteurs de
tâches qui peuvent sans doute est fait
par d'autres pour que les inspecteurs
soient présents sur le terrain ce qui
renvoie à ce que vous évoquez sur la
nécessité de contrôler que quand il ya
des prescriptions
elles sont effectivement mises en oeuvre
sur le rôle des assurances
d'abord moi je suis tout à fait
favorable à ce qui est dur est
préconisée par la mission d'information
de l'assemblée nationale qui puisse y
avoir une transmission des
recommandations de l'assurance aux
inspecteurs pour qu'ils puissent
évidemment être au courant de ces de ses
préconisations c'est un regard croisé
par contre je serais pas favorable à ce
qu'on mélange les rôles le regard de
l'assureur c'est pas le même que le
regard des inspecteurs le regard des
inspecteurs il se porte prioritairement
sur les risques les plus importants en
particulier les risques des taux
j'évoquais le fait que à l'occasion des
inspections et de la préparation du
pardon dans le cadre de l'étude de
dangers de lubrizol on a supprimé une
cuve gpl
c'est vraiment se concentrer sur ce
qu'ils présentent des risques en termes
de vies humaines ou
deux victimes le plus important
l'assurance a forcément un autre regard
sur les charges qui peuvent lui
incombait donc je pense que les deux
sont complémentaires ça me semble
important qu'on puisse avoir la
transmission aux dréal des
recommandations mais pour autant je
pense qu'on est aussi légitime à vouloir
poser des prescriptions plus opérantes
sur les conditions de stockage d'un
certain nombre de matières et c'est ce
qu'on va faire au travers des
modifications réglementaires que j'ai
annoncée s'agissant des as ce cas elles
sont au coeur des dispositifs de
surveillance de la qualité de l'air
elles n'ont pas toutes des astreintes
donc du coup c'est vrai qu'en
l'occurrence quand elles n'ont pas
d'astreinte on doit aussi trouver
d'autres acteurs qui qui peuvent
intervenir toute heure du jour et de la
nuit
mais les sk sont évidemment au coeur de
ces dispositifs de qualité de
surveillance de la qualité de l'air je
rappelle qu'ils sont sous l'autorité
personne mais qui sont agréés par l'état
et moi j'ai toute confiance dans ce qui
est produit par les à ce cas vous avez
peut-être noté qu'il y avait eu un début
de polémique à rouen puisque
lagence en question a fait le choix à un
moment donné d'arrêter de publier ces
indices ces mesures compte tenu du
décalage qui pouvait y avoir entre des
mesures qui paraissent c'est normal et
qui de fait porter sur des polluants qui
était en concentration normale dioxyde
de soufre de soufre d'azoté pm10 et
ozone et qui ne rendait pas compte de
faim voilà du ressenti de la population
qui pouvait difficilement accepter
l'idée que la qualité de l'air était
satisfaisante alors qu'on avait en
particulier notamment des problèmes
d'odeurs qui ont duré un certain temps
dans certains cas les assurances
paraissent plus exigeante que les
services de l'état puisque nous avions
il ya pas très longtemps il ya deux
heures ici même la soeur de lubrizol et
qui comme vous le savez a mis le doigt
sur des défaillances qui se sont révélés
malheureusement pertinente non pas les
défaillances mes mails et le pointage de
ces défaillances et je crois que
largement de lubrizol a été de dire mais
on est comme en conformité que la
réglementation donc sur ces points on a
plutôt le sentiment
sauf à ce que vous nous disiez n'inverse
que la réglementation est plus souple
que les prescriptions des assurances en
tout cas dans le cas de lubrizol c'est
ce qui nous a semblé comprendre alors je
pense que les enfin je ne suis pas en
train de vouloir opposer la
réglementation et les prescriptions
jeudi que la logique n'est pas la même
et qu'en l'occurrence les
recommandations qui avait été fait par
l'assurance était certainement
pertinente qu on aurait tort de se
priver de l' expertise de ses assureurs
et que je souscris à la proposition qui
a été faite par la mission d'information
de l'assemblée nationale que c'est ces
prescriptions soient systématiquement
transmises aux dryades
les défaillances soulevé par l'assurance
avait déjà été pointée du doigt en 2008
donc on est donc bien madame brûlé
monsieur le président madame la ministre
d'abord quelques éléments qui concerne
l'indemnisation
les indemnisations à la suite l'
incendie et notamment qui concerne les
agriculteurs parce que indemnisé il doit
visiblement signé une quittance
subrogation et une cession de droit qui
en gros dit qu'ils reconnaissent que le
règlement qui leur a été versée est à
titre définitif et qu'ils ne peuvent
plus par la suite soulevé d'éventuels
recours
ultérieurement or tout à l'heure encore
en a reçus des personnels de santé qui
nous disait la nécessité de faire des
études de santé au long cours et donc
moi je ne comprends pas et je n'accepte
pas qu'on puisse faire signer de
lubrizol puisse faire signer ce genre de
document en exigeant que par la suite il
n'y ait plus de recours parce qu'on ne
sait pas à l'heure actuelle s'il peut y
avoir des conséquences ultérieures
et évidemment ça c'est difficile que les
agriculteurs puissent signer ça de la
même manière quel recours existent pour
des producteurs qui considérerait que le
préjudice qu'ils ont subi n'a pas été
reconnue en totalité
aujourd'hui on ne connaît pas ses
recours qui concerne évidemment la
convention entre lubrizol existait qui
est le prestataire et le fonds de
mutualisation sanitaires et
environnementales d'ailleurs il ya des
agriculteurs qui ont témoigné du fait
que îlots ils ont des fins de non
recevoir à leurs demandes
d'indemnisation de la part des xix tech
sans aucune justification
tout ça pour dire que il me semble qu'il
faudrait que l'état que la puissance
publique globalement ne l'ès pas
l'ensemble de ces victimes parce que ce
sont bien deux victimes dont il s'agit
seul face à lui brise au loup à son
prestataire parce qu'on voit bien qu'on
n'est pas tout à fait dans un rapport de
force qui permet de se faire entendre ça
c'est la première des choses
deuxième chose qui commence a été qui a
commencé à être évoquée par mes
collègues c'est le projet de loi
d'accélération et de simplification de
l'action publique parce que il nous
semble quand même que peu de
d'enseignements de ce qui s'est passé
autour de lubrizol ont été pris en
compte
je me souviens que lors d'une de toute
première audition qui n'est même quitté
qui n'était même pas encore de cette
commission denquête mais de la
commission développement durable dans
laquelle je m'étais invités avec
précisément dans laquelle je m'étais
invités mais avec la bénédiction de son
président vous aviez vous-même d'entrée
de jeu et moi j'avais été sensible à
cette analyse là dit que c'était un
accident d'un type nouveau où il n'y
avait pas de victimes immédiates forte
heureusement mais peut-être et on le
souhaite évidemment pas mais des
conséquences à plus long terme et que ça
nécessiterait très certainement des
évolutions de la réglementation de la
législation alors vous faites un certain
nombre de propositions je les prends
bien évidemment content mais quand on
voit le projet de loi qui sera examinée
dans quelques jours au sénat on se dit
qu'on pourrait quand même aller un peu
plus loin et qu'en tout cas on pourrait
ne pas revenir en arrière sur le droit
de l'environnement parce qu'il ya
manifestement quand même des
assouplissements et des simplifications
qui sont évidentes et au delà du signe
que ça donne un des enseignements à
tirer de l'incendié de lubrizol c'est
quand même la défiance à l'égard de la
parole publique et n'avoir transcrit
dans ce projet de loi que les aspects
simplification du rapport casbah riant
est absolument aucun élément qui
concerne la culture du risque ou de la
sécurité ou qui concerne les enquêtes
publiques l'association des différents
partenaires je trouve que c'est
ne tenir aucun enseignement de l'
incendie de lubrizol et j'aimerais
vraiment que vous entendiez ce message
la ministre si alors sur l'indemnisation
des agriculteurs
moi je pense qu'ils peuvent tout à fait
avoir une réparation au civil pour
accélérer le processus il ya une sorte
de procédure transactionnel on va dire
qu'il a été mise en place par lubrizol
aussi les agriculteurs mais je vous
invite à poser plutôt la question
ministre de l'agriculteur de
l'agriculture pardon pense que cette
procédure n'est pas satisfaisante
il faut effectivement revoir avec
lubrizol les modalités des conditions de
cette indemnisation
franchement c'est vraiment mon collègue
de l'agriculture qui serait le mieux à
même de répondre je suis pas directement
en lien avec les agriculteurs pour vous
apporter des réponses sur le contenu des
indemnisations qui leur sont proposées
sur le projet de loi a zappé
je pense que vous aurez compris que ce
projet de loi a zappé n'est pas la
conséquence que le gouvernement tire de
l'accident lubrizol les conséquences que
l'on en tire sur la première partie
prévention à éviter qu'un tel incendie
se reproduise j'ai eu l'occasion de les
évoquer
pour l'essentiel ce sont des
dispositions de nature réglementaire la
création d'un bureau des enquêtes
accidents avec enfin qui soit une
véritable qu' une véritable indépendance
ce qui facilitera aussi les relations
avec l'autorité judiciaire
nécessitera une disposition législative
s'agissant du contenu donc je vous dis
ça n'est pas la conséquence de lubrizol
c'est des réflexions intérieures comme
vous l'avez pointé pour autant moi je
suis sensible au fait qu'une
simplification peut être lue comme une
régression et je vous dis on aura
l'occasion d'avoir des échanges avec des
associations de protection de
l'environnement qui sont très sensibles
sur ces sujets et j'y suis aussi
forcément sensible mais vous voyez je ne
pense pas qu'en mettant en cohérence les
règles relatives à la saisine du coderst
je pense qu'on peut tous reconnaître
qu'il est assez paradoxal que pour les
sites qui présentent les risques les
plus élevés et qui sont donc soumis à
autorisation aujourd'hui la consultation
du coderst est facultative pour la
catégorie qui présentent moins de
risques aujourd'hui elle est
systématique
je continue à penser que les préfets
feront preuve de bon sens et ne se dise
penseront pas de solliciter l'avis du
coderst sur un projet sensible sur
lequel il ya lieu d'avoir un maximum
d'éclairage autour de la décision que
j'ai également évoqué les dispositions
sur la possibilité dans des sites où il
n'y a pas d'enjeu en termes de loi sur
l'eau ou d'espèces protégées qui sont
d'ores et déjà artificialisées où il n'y
aurait pas besoin d'une autorisation de
défrichement de démarrer des travaux au
risque de celui qui porterait le projet
de ne pas avoir l'autorisation
environnementale
donc voilà je ne pense pas qu'on soit
enfin je pense qu'en aucun cas on est en
train d'assouplir ou de reculer sur la
réglementation des sites icpe
étant entendu que les mesures
on va dire pour mieux prévenir ces
incendies seront pour l'essentiel de
niveau réglementaire mais on pourra vous
les transmettre
dans l'esprit de ce que j'ai évoqués
vous faites un petit peu le pari que les
préfet de même rang à coeur de consulter
sur ses dimensions environnementales je
dirais monsieur le président que si on
part de l'idée que les préfets n'ont pas
une bonne appréciation des dossiers
sensibles
on voit aujourd'hui à quel point on a un
enjeu d'acceptabilité pour ses
installations
moi j'en retiens qu'on a plus que jamais
besoin de partager ces enjeux en amont
plutôt que de se dispenser quand on est
sur un sujet sensible d'en parler avec
les riverains avec les associations de
protection de l'environnement
je pense que si les préfets n'ont pas
perçu cette évolution et ses attentes
sociétales
il ya un problème et on pourra leur
rappeler même temps que vive
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je vous prie de m'excuser mais
je vais revenir sur deux points qui ont
déjà été évoqués l'article 24 donc qui
supprime la consultation systématique du
coderst vous venez de rappeler
qu'effectivement dans les commerces ne
peuvent s'exprimer les riverains peuvent
s'exprimer les associations de
l'environnement
les consommateurs le monde médical donc
la question que je me pose alors est
bien évident comme vous l'avez dit que
ce projet de loi n'arrive pas
précisément parce que il ya eu le brésil
c'est un fait mais je trouve qu'il y a
eu le brise hall et je partage les
propos de ma collègue céline brulin
quand même considérer que sur le terrain
dans le département est évidemment dans
les communes qui ont été concernés
l'émotion est toujours très vive
l'inquiétude est toujours très très
vives parce qu'il ya quand même des
incertitudes sur les conséquences
sanitaires
on le sait cela ne nous a été rappelé
tout à l'heure et est ce que justement
on n'aurait pas pu faire le gouvernement
n'aurait-il pas pu faire le choix
inverse c'est-à-dire d'aligner la
législation vers le haut avec une
consultation obligatoire du commerce et
de la cdm
est-ce plutôt que enfin pour les
installations des cpe plutôt que d'aller
vers le bas ce qui peut le plus peut le
moins et il me semble que la suite était
à mon avis une décision qui va dans le
sens de la démocratie environnementale
qui se développent et laquelle sont de
plus en plus attachés nos concitoyens
c'était la première chose
la deuxième chose de revenir aussi sur
sur l' axe 4 donc dû des nouvelles des
nouvelles des retours d'expérience qui
sont dans dans le rapport concernant le
renforcement donc des contrôles et donc
il est noté très clairement renforcé les
contrôles et se doter des moyens d'
enquête et on note qu'une réflexion qui
sera menée pour maintenir les
compétences rares et l'attractivité des
postes d'inspecteurs d'installations
classées
or j insiste sur le mot rare donc dans
un premier temps si j'ai bien compris
mais c'est pas les personnels
actuellement affectés à des tâches
administratives vont être transférés
donc à des tâches d'inspection est ce
que j'ai bien compris
si tel est le cas si tel est le cas
effectivement ses compétences rares
est-ce que c'est personnel dispose de
ses compétences rares la deuxième chose
et je reviens sur une question qui a
déjà été posée pour arriver dans les
cinq ans à obtenir se dire est ce ce
corps d'inspecteurs qui devront
contrôler et donc ses installations
classées mais on a aussi qu'il y aura
des contrôles ciblés sur les sites
seveso en élargissant le périmètre et en
prenant en compte tout l'environnement
de ces sites cela suppose donc des
personnels nombreux
indépendamment de la formation quel
crédit seront affectés à la formation de
ses personnels et at on estimé
effectivement le nombre de ces
personnels nécessaires au vu des
nombreux sites seveso classés seuil haut
sur notre territoire
je vous remercie merci même truc film
ministre alors
sur la consultation des coderst je
voudrais vous dit vous faire expliciter
ce que peut être une installation soumis
à déclaration ou à enregistrement par
exemple vous pouvez avoir des tripes
déchets non dangereux
vous pouvez avoir des entrepôts de
cartons en zone artificialisés moi je
pense que il n'est pas inutile de
permettre de consacrer les débats du
commerce aux dossiers les plus sensibles
sous l'appréciation du préfet mais si on
part de l'idée que les préfets vont mal
utiliser ce pouvoir d'appréciation il ya
en effet un problème je pense que doit
plutôt partir de l'idée que les préfets
peuvent faire la différence entre un
installations sensibles et évidemment le
coderst a été consulté sur le
redémarrage très partielle du site
lubrizol mais peut-être que d'être
consultés sur une installation de tri de
déchets non dangereux n'a pas la même
sensibilité
donc moi je continue à penser que cette
faculté de cette possibilité qui
finalement donné de consacrer tout le
temps des débats du coderst a des
dossiers
dossiers les plus importants nous semble
une bonne faculté mais ensuite ça peut
ça peut évidemment se débattre sur la
réalisation des contrôles
il s'agit pas de d'affecter à des
inspections des agents qui auraient des
compétences pour gérer des dossiers des
procédures administratives
je fais le constat qu alors même que les
effectifs ont sensiblement augmenté le
nombre de contrôles a diminué ce que
j'explique par le fait qu'on a mobilisé
nos inspecteurs sur l'élaboration des
pprt il ya certainement aussi le
classement des éoliennes en
installations classées qui est un sujet
qui leur prend du temps mais je pense
qu'il ya aussi des tâches
administratives dont on peut les
décharges et donc l'idée n'est pas
d'affecter des gens ayant des
compétences administratives à des tâches
d'inspection mais de décharger les
inspecteurs de tâches administratives
qui peuvent être fait autrement
et donc c'est comme ça qu'on pourra
redonner à ces mission d'inspecteurs
enfin je pense qu'il s'agit de voilà de
les recentrer sur leur coeur de métier
parce que ce sont effectivement des
compétences très précieuse qui n'est pas
utile de détourner au profit de tâches
administratives qui peuvent soit être
mieux gérée par des logiciels adaptés
soit être fait par d'autres
merci monsieur vial oui moins 20 minutes
quand on arrive au terme dé des travaux
des auditions une question qui m'amène
davantage ailleurs sur le volet de la
responsabilité plutôt alors ce n'est pas
que le domaine des risques du contrôle
ne soit pas au contraire mais il était
longuement évoquée et on voit bien qu'il
y a le champ effectivement de la loi du
règlement et de toutes les mesures qui
ont été largement
échanger ce soir mais il y a le droit
commun quand on oublier un petit peu
c'est le principe de la responsabilité
il a évolué il a évolué au cours des
événements après seveso d'azf toulouse
erica est aujourd'hui lubrizol
on a eu jusqu'à pas si longtemps que ça
un principe de responsabilité qu'ils
aient le principe de responsabilité du
droit commun 382 depuis napoléon et puis
on a eu effectivement dans un deuxième
temps avec l'erika notamment le principe
responsabilité environnementale des
pollueurs payeurs et puis plus récemment
avec la loi du 8 août 2016
le préjudice écologique donc on voit
effectivement que ce principe de
responsabilité de droit commun c'est à
fidéliser et je les votes pour rejoindre
les questions qui ont été évoquées tout
à l'heure en matière d'indemnisation
on a vu que concernant lubrizol
il ya eu des propositions
d'indemnisation à laurière il ya
toujours le côté un petit peu en se
disant baisse que l'industriel ne fait
pas un geste un petit peu psychologique
commercial excusez l'expression pour
montrer sa bonne foi m'essayer en même
temps ça a été soulevée tout à l'heure
de passer des conventions pour dire je
verse une indemnité une année dix
nations forfaitaire je signe une
convention valant seul de tout compte
et puis c'est terminé voilà donc on voit
bien que les choses ont évolué et
qu'elle évolue dans le bon sens mais
aujourd'hui au regard effectivement de
la sphère lubrizol comme j'évoquais les
autres les autres incidents passés qui
ont amené à l'évolution de la loi
j'ai vu révoquer les deux les deux
évolutions est ce qu'on peut considérer
aujourd'hui que nous avons un cadre
jst hâtif qui est satisfaisant ou si la
sphère plus le l'événement lubrizol a
fait apparaître effectivement des
situations qui mériteraient d'être
affinés
je parle du coût de l'indemnisation
puisque effectivement la presse en a
beaucoup parlé mais malheureusement nous
savons peu de comment les choses se sont
mis en oeuvre comment elles ont été
contrôlées et comment elle pourrait
s'améliorer pour être sûr effectivement
que les dommages puisse être aider
rapidement sans priver les droits ça a
été évoqué tout à l'heure pour les
agriculteurs c'est toujours le risque
d'avoir une indemnisation qu'ils soient
versés rapidement sans que ça éteignent
les droits des deux de ceux qui ont des
préjudices estimés immédiatement ou qui
peuvent apparaître dans le temps merci
merci monsieur vial madame ministre
enfin moi je pense que aujourd'hui on a
un arsenal juridique qui est important
pour s'assurer d'abord qui affirme très
clairement la responsabilité sur les
conséquences tous les préjudices
environnementaux qui eux que génère un
exploitant ce principe là il est il est
absolument clair
ensuite c'est vrai qu'en l'occurrence on
sait très bien que les procédures et les
jugements peuvent intervenir tardivement
d'où l'idée qu' il pouvait être utile
que le l'industriel
assume la responsabilité d'indemnisation
sans attente des décisions au civil moi
je ne sais pas quelles sont les
conditions proposées par lubrizol et je
ne sais pas si c'est satisfaisant
je ne sais pas comment ont été évalués
les préjudices si c'est la perte
instantanée des productions agricoles ou
si le préjudice
la suspicion on peut dire sur les
produits issus de la zone ont bien été
prises en compte je ne sais pas en tout
cas il ya des procédures pour assurer la
réparation des préjudices par
l'industriel en cause qui fonctionne
bien c'est vrai que dans le même état
d'esprit
vous avez sans doute eu l'occasion de
débattre de la convention judiciaire
écologique qui nous semble une voie
intéressante à creuser par analogie avec
ce qui existe par exemple en terme de
corruption ou de fraude
c'est ce qui a conduit récemment airbus
à devoir payer 2,6 milliards d'euros
donc on voit que c'est des outils qui
sont très puissants pour obtenir des
réparations large des préjudices
donc je pense que c'est intéressant
qu'on puisse doter d'outils
complémentaires et ça ne pourra être
aussi évoquée dans le cadre des débats
du projet de loi sur la justice
environnementale
moi je pense mais on est en train de
continuer à l'expertisé qu'il ya
peut-être des trous dans la raquette sur
les sanctions en terme d'atteinte à
l'environnement qui pourraient justifier
d'avoir un délit d'atteinte général
alors à l'environnement comme on a
aujourd'hui des délits de mise en danger
de la vie d'autrui
donc c'est une réflexion qu'on est
encore en train d'approfondir
il me semble qu'il ya un certain nombre
de cas où les sanctions qui sont
encourues pour non respect d'un certain
nombre de prescriptions sont
insuffisantes au regard de l'ampleur du
préjudice
donc du coup on est en train de 2 et en
même temps il s'agirait pas de créer une
instabilité juridique pour les
industriels qui se sont conformés en
toute bonne foi
aux prescriptions qui ont été données
mais moi j'ai en tête sans dénoncer
personne un certain nombre de cas d'un
industriel dans le centre de la france
dont les stockages ont brûlé pendant
trois mois d'affilée
il est passible aujourd'hui d'une
d'une sanction au titre du non respect
des capacités de stockage de son site
ça me semble pas à la hauteur du
préjudice qui a été créée voilà donc
peut-être qu'on aura outre la convention
judiciaire écologique porté dans le
projet doit de nicole belloubet à
réfléchir sur la façon dont on traite ce
genre de situation où la sanction n'est
manifestement pas à la hauteur du
préjudice
tout ceci allant de pair aussi avec un
sujet dont vous avez peut-être débattu
avec nicole belloubet sur notre volonté
de renforcer les sanctions sur les
atteintes à l'environnement de revoir un
peu l'échelle des peines qui est aussi
une réflexion sur laquelle on est en
train de caen est en train de mener
merci monsieur leur faim merci ce
présent madame la ministre
beaucoup de choses ont déjà été évoqués
moi je voudrais revenir sur deux sujets
que vous avez évoquées dans votre propos
introductif concernant les améliorations
que vous souhaitez apporter en matière
de politique de prévention concernant
les établissements seveso ainsi que les
politiques de prévisions c'est deux
choses totalement différentes
vous avez évoqué tout d'abord moi je
souscris à cette obligation et je parle
pas là des faits cocktail mais d'effet
domino faire en sorte d'éviter que la
propagation d'un établissement à un
autre se réalise et donc limiter cette
propagation par des compartimentage est
plus important magrez complètement ça
c'est la première chose deuxième chose
en ce qui concerne la politique de
prévention et prévisions cette fois ci
et je voulais évoquer quelque chose qui
me tient à coeur c'est les exercices en
matière d'établissements recevant du
public
on a régulièrement des exercices qui ont
lieu je pense notamment aux
établissements scolaires en début
d'année scolaire ça se passe à sous
l'autorité du chef d'établissement en y
associant d'ailleurs le maire de la
commune
mais là on
dans une situation totalement différente
puisque là il s'agit de les pouvoirs de
police administrative générale qui sont
assumés par le maire de la commune alors
que nous sommes en matière de
d'établissement 10 classés en politique
dite spéciale et qui relève des pouvoirs
du préfet ces questions de l'exercice on
le voit très bien notamment dans le
département de la seine maritime on a un
département qui est qui accueille si je
puis me permettre ainsi le nombre
d'établissements seveso le plus
important de france
c'est le département de la seine
maritime et on voit très bien qu'entre
le havre port jérôme d'un côté et la
métropole rouennaise il y a eu un
développement de la culture du risque
du côté du havre où depuis pas mal
d'années il y assez régulièrement des
exercices qui est qui sont organisées
donc moi je voudrais vous dire que ces
exercices à mes yeux sont indispensables
pour permettre aux populations et
notamment aux plus jeunes d'entre eux
les scolaires de pouvoir intégrer ce qui
n'était pas le cas on est plusieurs du
département moi j'étais présent du
département de la seine-maritime et
encore quelques mois où les habitants
des communes concernées n'avaient pas
totalement réalisé ce que générer
potentiellement les risques des
établissements seveso implanté sur la
métropole rouennaise et donc ces
conduites à tenir ses réflexes il faut
en permanence les rappeler à la
population les rappeler bien sûr aux
entreprises voisines y associer le maire
de la commune ou des communes voisines
parce qu'on le on l'a très bien vu
également un des réflexes premier des
habitants c'est de se tourner
vers le maire ils font fi des subtilités
des différentes police des polices
administratives et donc ces exercices
moi je souhaite qu'ils soient réguliers
qu'ils soient nocturne ou pas forcément
en nocturne
mais en même temps que vous parlez d'une
autre problématique qui est à la
constitution de réserves des musées
heures effectivement pour éteindre les
feux d'hydrocarbures il faut de les
mineurs et sur un feu comme celui de
lubrizol aucun service départemental
d'incendié et secours ou d'entreprises
aujourd'hui n'avait les capacités sol en
termes dé mille soeur à pouvoir éteindre
un tel sinistre alors il existe des
conventions de mutualisation de
solidarité entre les différentes
entreprises entre les différences 10 moi
je voudrais et j'en terminerai là qu'à
l'occasion de ces à ces exercices
l'ensemble des coûts supportés temps par
la puissance publique
anton caussels quand on connaît la
tension des budgets des dix que par les
entreprises soient financées par les
entreprises seveso pour supporter les
coûts de ces exercices alors les mules
soeur ça coûte cher ça coûte même très
très cher il ne semble pas logique qu'en
termes d'exercice ça soit en partie la
puissance publique donc les 10 qui
supportent les coûts de ces exercices
bien sûr lorsqu'il y a non plus un
exercice mène une opération comme nous
l'avons connu qu'il y ait de
participation de la puissance publique à
l'extinction de ce sinistre est une
évidence mais en termes d'exercice je
résume les rendre obligatoires
il y associer l'ensemble des partenaires
le samu les polices municipales les
policiers bien sûr les dix la commune
concernée et que la prise en charge soit
intégralement supportés par les
entreprises générant potentiellement
serristes voilà merci monsieur martin le
ministre merci donc je vous confirme
qu'effectivement des dispositions deux
entre pour limiter des effets dominos
c'est d'abord la révision de la
réglementation sur les stockages dans
les entrepôts donc on a engagé les
concertations avec les fédérations
professionnelles pour finaliser les
nouvelles dispositions réglementaires et
puis donc l'inspection dans les cent
mètres autour des sites seveso seuil
haut sur la gestion de crise la culture
du risque donc on a une mission
d'inspection dont on attend les retours
moi je pense qu'on peut se dire
effectivement que d'une part et puis par
ailleurs pardon excusez moi il ya quand
même effectivement le fait de passer à
des exercices obligatoires tous les ans
sur les sites seveso seuil haut et non
pas la recommandation qui est le cas
aujourd'hui
tous les trois ans ensuite moi je suis
assez frappé de ce que vous dites sur la
différence de culture de risque selon
finalement le bassin industriel
je suis aussi frappé pour avoir
malheureusement eu à me déplacer dans le
cadre de risques naturels sur le fait
que je pense que les les
mr ont vraiment pris à bâle à bras le
corps dans le cadre de leurs plans
communaux de sauvegarde
la question des risques naturels et moi
j'ai eu je pense que si on a eu certes
des victimes
mais fort heureusement en nombre
relativement limité malgré des
inondations qui ont frappé notre pays
l'automne dernier c'est parce que
finalement je crois que les maires se
sont vraiment saisi dans leurs plans
communaux de sauvegarde de cette culture
du risque naturel
je pense que ça n'est certainement fins
ça me semble être nettement moins le cas
sur la question des risques industriels
on a certainement à réfléchir à la façon
dont on peut renforcer cette culture sur
les risques industriels les instances de
concertation qui existent aujourd'hui
alors elle existe à la fois sur chaque
site cédé ancien client css douala des
comités de suivi des sites finalement ne
me semble pas répondre à la question de
la diffusion de l'information
la bonne information des riverains sur
l'existence de risques et la façon dont
ils peuvent se manifester et la façon
dont il faut réagir si jamais ce risque
est avéré
donc on a effectivement certainement un
champ à compléter sur la culture du
risque industriel à l'image de ce qu'on
a malheureusement eu l'occasion de faire
suite à différentes catastrophes
naturelles ces dernières années oui
monsieur martin rapidement ce genre de
demandes de parents très rapidement la
dernière question que je vous ai posé
sur le financement des exercices
lancements des exercices pour moi les
sur les émulseur ce sont les industriels
qui financent aujourd'hui et pas les 10
donc c'est à l'industriel qu'il
appartient de disposer des produits
nécessaires à l'extinction de son
incendie
ensuite la mobilisation du sdi cela
peut-être à creuser merci monsieur
tissot oui merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre
juste une informations complémentaires à
propos des de l'assureur on a auditionné
tout à l'heure je lui ai posé la
question clairement en le demandant une
fois l'état des lieux fait en soulignant
les améliorations que pourrait apporter
lubrizol est ce que là la prime
d'assurance seraient moins chers
il m'a confirmé que oui donc c'est un
peu un conflit d'intérêts parce que quel
intérêt il a une entreprise pour gagner
de l'argent donc je sais pas s'il a
intérêt à ce que finalement non je suis
peut-être un peu brutes mais ce n'est
qu'une question que je pose et une
deuxième question et ça a été mon fil
rouge tout au long de ces de ces
auditions
et comme c'est la dernière c'est à
propos de l'eau voilà dans cette même
salle christophe castaner m'avait
confirmé que l'eau de la darse qui enfin
la darse qui avait servi de stockage
pour l'eau polluée pour éteindre le site
ces taux étaient donc polluer et ma
question est claire comment avez vous
est ce que borloo et dépollué et qu'est
devenu cet os révulsé tholot stocker
cette 1re ministre alors donc moi je
retiens que les assureurs enfin qu'on a
une réglementation nationale qui fixe
finalement des règles à respecter par
tous les industriels que
enfin les préfets peuvent renforcer en
fonction de la configuration du site et
je pense que le regard des assureurs
dont je redis que leur lecture est
différente c'est à dire que eux ce qui
va les intéresser
c'est finalement les mesures qui peuvent
réduire le risque économique qui in fine
et leur retomberez dessus en cas
d'accident en tout cas c'est vrai que
les recommandations qui peuvent être
amenés à faire sont précieuses je pense
que pour le pour le l'assureur avoir
moins de primes mais ne pas avoir à
gérer un sinistre ça reste ça reste
certainement financièrement très utiles
sur la darphin donc les opérations de
dépollution sont aujourd'hui terminés
donc c'était à la fois
alors l'ol même elle avait été là
j'étais pardon confinés pendant fin on a
pu mettre en place des protections grâce
à l'intervention notamment des services
du port la destruction de la faune était
lié à une sous oxygénation de l'eau à ce
moment là et donc ça c'est quelque chose
qui est revenue à la normale par contre
contenu des dés
et de l'évacuation des eaux d'extinction
de l'incendié il ya eu un travail
important de dépollution notamment de
nettoyage des quais des enrochements de
l'émissaire lui même j'entends ce que
les clients ont été nettoyées mais c'est
vraiment parce qu'en fait tu la caution
défendra les fondamentale qu'est devenu
l'eau polluée est ce qu'on leur balance
et la scène une oreille enfin jambes
mais c'est des millions de mètres cubes
coin je voulais chanter mais je vais
vérifier mais je pense pas que les
services en charge de la dépollution
envoie de l'eau polluée comme ça dans la
salle mais je vérifier jeu
je veux juste oui c'est ma question il
semble vraisemblable que quel soit aller
quelque part quand même cette zone ne
pense pas qu'elle se soit évaporé l'eau
d'extinction l'eau d'extinction d'abord
elle aurait dû être stocké dans des
bassins de rétention
ouais mais ça on sait que c'est pas ça
pas été le cas donc ça n'a pas été le
cas et l'eau qui a été collecté pour moi
elle était renvoyée dans des sites de
dépollution de la région je dois
vérifier alors c'est parce qu'on ne
dirait aujourd'hui ça me convient bien
qu'on veut bien mais c'est parce que
nous ajoute je préférerais mais je
vérifier d'accord merci ça paraît ça
paraît compliqué quand même compte tenu
des volumes d'eau en question qu'on ait
pu tout stocker tous transférés parce
que le bon bah vous nous ferez vous un
petit titre réponse écrite pour terminer
même cartron moi je vais arriver en fin
de parcours
je vais rebondir sur ce qui nous avait
été dit justement dès les premières
auditions
la non culture du risque qui était
intégrée par les par les habitants et
donc je le couple avec les quelques
visites que j'ai fait sur le terrain en
gironde puisqu'on a un certain nombre d'
usine seveso
donc seuil haut et j'ai vu une prise en
compte
très différente des élus de cette
culture du risque et de cette
information faite aux populations à la
fois parce que quelquefois lorsque l'
usine est vraiment en coeur de cité
l'information est fait
lorsqu'elle se trouve
dans la campagne à côté d'un village y
est il ya un village où il ya une usine
d'artifice là le maire ne m'a dit moi je
ne fais aucune information c'est à côté
bon on verra bien si ça donc je pense
qu'il ya un besoin d'accompagner les
maires parce que il y a une
la peur de faim d'inquiéter de façon
abusive la peur aussi de de stigmatiser
la commune et donc je pense que il leur
faut un accompagnement fort pour pouvoir
justement permettre aux habitants de
s'approprier en toute quiétude
ce qui est cette culture du risque et
puis là la deuxième question que
j'aimerais poser c'est où en sommes nous
et quelle procédure par rapport à la
remise en marche de lusine je sais qu'il
ya une remise en marche partiel qu'est
ce qu'il en est des phases qui pourrait
qui pourrait suivre
comment avec quelques accompagnements et
qui prendrait les décisions avec après
un dernier l'a vraiment dire que par
rapport à la loi de simplification
moi je partage les doutes par rapport au
signal qui pourrait être envoyée dans le
contexte actuel de justement on pourrait
interpréter qu'on baisse la garde et
c'est c'est bien de faire confiance au
préfet il n'y a pas de raison de ne pas
leur faire confiance
parfois c'est après un peu compliqué
merci l'imamat ministre merci enfin sur
le dernier point enfin parlement est
souverain sur le vote de la loi
moi je vous ai exposé d'un point de vue
strictement technique
je dirai ce qu'il en est sûr est ce
qu'on est en train ou pas de baisser la
garde
je ne pense pas ensuite il ya des
symboles et je l'entends sur la culture
du risque
moi j'entends ce que ce que vous dites
est vraiment c'est l'objet de la
deuxième mission intérêts spéciaux qui
est en cours je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
a des structures de concertation les
commissions de suivi site d secrétariat
permanent pour la prévention des
pollutions industrielles et des risques
enfin je je je ne pense pas que ça
favorise l'appropriation de ces enjeux
de risques industriels par la population
comme on pourrait le souhaiter
donc il ya certainement à progresser
dans ce domaine
c'est vrai qu'on a un certain nombre de
pays
enfin vous avez sens nous dit que le
japon organise des journées sur les
risques bon c'est quelque chose aussi
auquel on a réfléchi dans les outre-mer
mais plus sur la partie risque naturel
en tout cas il ya certainement un enjeu
de d'appropriation de ces risques sur le
redémarrage de l'installation donc on
est enfin on a eu une demande de
l'industriel sur cette partie
strictement limitée à ce stade on n'a
pas de demande d'autorisation à ma
connaissance de la part de l'industriel
est par ailleurs les enquêtes
judiciaires qui est toujours en cours
donc voilà je peux pas
parler de l'instruction d'un dossier qui
n'est pas aujourd'hui déposé voilà pour
cette audition d'elisabeth bornes la
ministre de la transition écologique
propose notamment de renforcer les
sanctions en terme d'atteinte à
l'environnement elle évoque par exemple
la création d'un délit d'atteinte à
l'environnement
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
rester avec une information politique
continue sur public sénat